hornets lead by five  largest lead had been six edwards pretty  much  oh oh that's what all the fuss is about  yes boy we're being  looked at first time edward look at that  the screen and roll and then up and  under with a hang time  lamella answers with a three of its  own and three is better than two how  about that  lamello  [Applause]  oh a gorgeous dime from lavello he  should  lamello a power dribble scores at the  rim  this kid's 180 pounds  rookie edwards that's a nice move yeah  he's going to be a really good scorer in  this league  lamelo  so does that kid  [Applause]  head on a swivel and sees carl anthony  go down the lane and towns  back out to edwards biz on him  [Applause]  wow all right how low he gets yeah  yeah and then explodes with the contact  31 flavors no screen required  loose head of the pack cody zella what  do you got